all right um uh uh I'm going to call the
uh executive session of the uh Judiciary
Committee to order and I'm going to
recognize uh representative lonza to
Alle States America the for stands one
nation
glance all right
um we're going to uh I'm going to turn
to uh House Bill
10002 uh
first and
um my sense is um as as we discussed um
at our in in the Republican caucus last
night and now based upon the discussions
I've had with the ranking member uh this
morning my sense is that we are divided
on this on a sort of bipartisan basis
there are uh Republicans and Democrats
on both sides that uh favor the bill and
that do not and so um I guess what I'd
like to do is um is take a straw vote uh
before we have an actual vote on this uh
and then my my plan candidly would be
that whichever whichever side is in the
majority I would recognize that person
to make the motion uh for whatever side
that is uh we'll take a vote on that and
then we'll have uh those of us if if if
if we're the ones that are on the losing
side if they want to uh uh write a
Minority Report that that's fine too um
so I guess um the other thing I'd like
to discuss is those I personally favor
the bill particularly um with the
amendment uh made by offered by
representative katab but I guess what
I'd like to
throw out for discussion is this for
those who don't favor it I'm wondering
is I mean this would I think help uh
help our discussion is is your position
sort of absolute we just don't think
that there should be any provision for
costs under any circumstances or are
there you know is there room for
allowing costs in some circumstance
because I think that might that might
make a difference to those of us who who
who favor it um at least personally I
would be open
you know I'm not saying it has to be the
way the the uh representative cutab has
it or nothing um so that's so I throw it
open to
discussion so if I understand you you
want discussion first before we take a
straw V right if we could
yeah um so represent representative L um
andw thank you Mr chair
even though this bill is well
intended and I totally understand it I
am totally against it we are taking away
the rights of our citizens whether we
like it or not and far as I'm concerned
we don't have that right I have
had
numerous times with especially my school
district I have had to ask for
information under right to know no I
have a right to no request in my school
district right
now and because the law says I can ask
for it under a different law because
it's transfer of
funds it may take over 10 hours and do
you mean the school district is may have
the right to charge me for it because
the law at tells me I can ask for this
information if Government any of it was
100 100%
honest and
transparent we wouldn't be have this
problem today now as far as records go
I've been around for a long time I've
been in office work all my life I know
how things pretty well work I've been in
state government I've been in County
government working and I know how things
pretty well
work one person may take 10 hours to
find something another person may take
two hours to find something why is it
right to
charge a person a citizen if somebody
just takes longer then we have a
position in some of our towns and
municipalities and cities etc etc I
don't like you so I'm going to charge
you more I'm going to take more time or
oh I like you so I'm not going to charge
you so much we have a problem there then
there's something I looked up this
morning I happen to think
of there is a records retention law in
the state of New
Hampshire and in that
list it tells every record every
municipality every agency that needs to
keep on
record now if everybody doesn't follow
this
law
and keeps everything in order like it
should be because some records you don't
have to keep forever some records you
have to retain permanently if you can't
keep these laws in order and you have to
hunt and hunt for information
something's wrong and that's not the
citizens fault so like I said even
though this bill is well intentioned I
will definitely vote against
top thank you Mr chair um so I just
don't think that
having taxpayers subsidize one
person's fishing Expedition
or a
business's ploy to get information
that's going to financially benefit
them I just don't think it's fiscally
responsible and you know I
think we need to consider that a lot of
towns are are paying attorneys to redact
many of these requests we're not talking
about getting meeting minutes and that
kind of stuff that should of course
always be available it's available on
many of the town's web page what we're
really talking about here is the
requests that are for multiple emails
for a significant period of time back
and I think similar to what rip Andrews
was talking about about records
retention there's nothing in there that
actually lists that you even need to
keep emails so do we want the towns to
turn to having no other recourse but to
just start deleting emails um I
certainly don't think that that's you
know what we're wanting here and I I
just think you know the Constitution
does say that we shall not unreasonably
restrict and I think unreasonably
restrict is the key key word here
because nothing in the current statute
defines what is reasonable nothing gives
any meth method of of pushing back if a
town doesn't feel that that's reasonable
sure that they can say I don't think
this is reasonable and the person can
just say well I want it anyway and the
town's forced to do it this is giving 10
free hours in a month I think if you get
your 10 hours of records and you want
more you could wait another month give
somebody else a turn to get their
records that they may need as well so
for that reason I'm going to be
supporting the Bill thank
you other other comments uh yes
representative Smith thank thank you Mr
chair as the chairman well
knows um we sometimes find ourselves in
the judicial branch with frivolous
lawsuits and they are a nuisance and
they take time and they get in the
way but they're not all that many of
them and to and it's always within the
power of the core cour to get rid of a
frivolous
lawsuit it's a small price to pay to
maintain democracy small D
democracy uh I believe the
[Music]
same rubric
applies in this case I had a long
conversation with my Town
Administrator and as asked him about
what the problems were with right to
know in
dur
and he said uh every now and then we do
get somebody who is orary just for
the enjoyment of being orary he said but
if the town government recognizes the
Public's right to
know right to know then there's so many
ways to handle it um someone writes and
says I need every piece of
Correspondence that you have on such and
such going back since um Adam and
Eve and so what you do is you pick up
the phone and you call and
say what do you really what do you
really want let me know what you really
want let's see if we can figure out how
we can do this and it turns out he
really wants a particular letter or a
group of uh letters that communicate
about something and then the answer is
sure come on
down and um and we'll get those for you
if you assume good
faith until in the rare situation you
find find out that it is not good
faith you can accomplish an awful
lot I I think that right to know doesn't
have the system in the state doesn't
have everything down perfectly nothing
we do is perfect it's one of the reasons
that we created the udman to see for a
limited period of time to see if that is
helpful
but I believe very strongly that Our
obligation is to make sure that citizens
are able to get all the
information that they can
reasonably expect obviously not
violating certain
confidentiality that can't be uh altered
and that a system that puts a price on
it is on its face
discriminatory it is going to on its
face hurt people at the lowest end of
the income
scale um it is going to set up different
classes of people as to whether or not
you're entitled to get
information and we know that we could
charge a lot and big commercial entities
aren't going to care at all they can pay
whatever but I'm not concerned about
them I'm concerned about the individual
and that is why I feel very strongly um
that while we always can look for ways
to improve right to know this is not the
way thank you any other other comments
uh yes uh representative tur first and
then representative
Stapleton um yeah thanks Mr chair I I
just wanted to speak in in favor of this
um some of the things have been
mentioned already and I totally
differential to um the comments that
were made by people who have done this
for a lot longer than I have just now um
both reps Andress and and Smith um I as
as as many often happens it feels like
this is you know a response to something
that's sort of becoming a grow
tactic if I'll call it you know very
often there are things that are very
good things until until some folks
decide that they want to start using
them a different way and and uh I don't
think this will completely solve that
problem um I feel like from what we
heard from the gathered statistics on
this there would be very
few cases that would fall into this
because the 10hour threshold is rarely
exceeded um and I feel as though the um
there are two purposes really if this
were to happen one is the the the
associated cost would for I think hope
bring people to to think more about the
limits of what they're asking for um the
the the really difficult ones that I've
seen are very open-ended it's all
Communications across multiple you know
boards and committees um you know and
those are the ones that sort of don't
seem to have a purpose but seem to be
use those are the ones that take you
know hundreds and hundreds of pages and
you know someone has to redact them um
and it also to to compensate so so both
to cause people to think and also to
limit the time um and you know again I
think we we'll discuss today maybe a
bill that might also further limit the
amount of time that's needed if you
could if if towns are producing things
that are already electronically in
electronic format could further limit
the amount of time uh that's needed and
and I feel feel like there is an out um
with the
Ombudsman um to basically make sure that
the types of abuses where where uh a
town might just claim a very very large
amount of time would be um would be
dealt with through that process so um
that's my thoughts thank you
representative
Stapleton thank you Mr chair um
representative Smith touched upon a
golden Point
communication
communication much preferable than
loggerheads and um my thought is that if
uh we had the 10hour and monetary
factors that would be a very much of an
incentive for people to communicate and
say what do you really want because if
we go over a limit and you want
everything in the world then it could be
costly and it sets people back back to
think communication and thinking I view
this bill as a balancing between the
right to know um citizens in democracy
wanting to know what's going on in
government and the the protecting
communities especially small communities
municipalities from outrageous costs I
know in Claremont we had a couple of
issues that went to attorneys in 201
$225,000 worth of uh attorney time
investigating and letters and expunging
personal information and so on and so
forth um just tremendously costly and I
think this bill represents a balancing
effect um and and I think it's
positive other other comments Mr yes
representative G
Lorenzo thank you for taking my question
um you know
we've had four days to study this bill
um
we took it on
um on
the 17th and today's the 22nd 7 and four
is 12 yeah that's so four four days for
me that's really not enough time uh this
bill is really complex um my initial
take on it is I would want to go itail
on it because there's too much here and
we don't have enough time to really mes
out you know all the issues
so that's my thought thank you you know
I'm sorry other yes representative Smith
I could just uh add one comment bad
cases make bad law um I think the
municipal Association itself gave us
material which show that
overwhelmingly requests are um
are of
modest
import um it is the um
outlier uh that seems to get people um
concerned enough in order to want to
move with this bill those are in the
minority I continue to believe that if
public employees were familiar with more
so perhaps than they are with the best
way to keep records with their
obligations under right to know and
understanding that someone asking for
something isn't the
enemy the person asking
is is new is a neutral force and should
be viewed as a neutral Force until
something happens that makes you
understand that it's not and in order to
protect the overwhelm Welling majority
of the citizens of the state and honor a
commitment to right to know recognize
that
secrecy as compared with
transparency is not actually the best
way to function in a
democracy um I think the bill is an
example of a bad case making a bad law
and I I obviously don't want to belabor
the point anymore but I hope we would
focus our attention
on the problems that
affect significantly more of the people
in this state than the few outliers who
might be abusing the system thank you
other comments so I guess that that I I
just want to make um one uh one sort of
final uh comment on this um I I think I
I I largely agree with the sentiments
that have been expressed by everyone the
one thing where I would I think disagree
with the ranking member is I do think I
mean I agree that most of the requests
there isn't any problem and that's not
what this bill is is aimed at but I
agree with representative tur that there
and I think we've seen
increasing examples of this that there
are are people who are just out to abuse
the system who believe you know who have
these kind of conspiracy theories and
and please don't misunderstand me I'm
not saying that there that some of the
things that representative Andress
pointed out are there some small towns
where you know there is a click and
there's some favorites and non-f
favorites I'm sure that's true but as a
general proposition you know I are my
sense is that the people public servants
are generally pretty good people who are
out who are trying to do the right thing
and just as I as I think all the people
around this table fit into that category
um and um unfortunately there are some
people who have this uh mindset that
let's let's see if we can screw up the
works uh in some way by asking for
everything making and of course the
result of that is that um the taxpayers
all of us end up paying because
Municipal Employees or state employees
who should be doing other things that
we're paying them for are instead
involved in in uh
uh responding to these requests and as I
think we've heard from the the evidence
here the the best example of that is one
the witness who indicated that you know
they're they have a they have so many of
these things for large volumes of
information that they've they've spent
in in ordinate amount of time Gathering
and the people haven't even bothered to
come and pick it up um which I think
demonstrates um what you know what the
intent is in many of those cases the
last thing I'll say is and I this this
goes back well over 30 years but I I use
this as an example of the fact that in
some circumstances you know having
requiring people to have a little skin
in the game really does matter when I
was in the US attorney's office in
Boston I had this big uh fraud mortgage
fraud case and was in uh the early 90s
and I think we indicted about 10
defendants nine of them were people that
were you know very well off financially
and could afford to hire their own
lawyers and they did one of them was who
was sort of the one of the low low rung
people that was charged um was not able
to afford a lawyer and he ended up with
the federal public
defender in the course of Discovery uh
there was a there were lots and lots of
documents as you might imagine in a case
like this the nine lawyers who were rep
the nine defendants who were represented
by in by private councel who were going
to have to pay for their their
attorney's time all of them
made extensive but very reasonable
records requests about what they wanted
from the government's files that had
some bearing that were reasonably had
some bearing on what could be relevant
in the case but the one who had a public
defender just said I want everything I
want every scrap of paper uh whether it
it would have any potential relevance or
not and and why because they weren't
going to pay for it and what and it was
it was very obvious to me that they were
never going to look at at any of the
much of the stuff that theyve they asked
for that had really you know little or
no relevance and they knew that too but
if you're if there's no skin in the game
and it doesn't cost you a dime why not
ask for it um and I use that as an
example because and of course we gave it
to them they were you know they were
entitled to it under the under the rules
and of course we we spent a lot of time
and gave it to them um but that's just
an example of and I of of when it makes
sense to require people to have some
skin in the game and I think this
amendment with particularly with
representative kav's Amendment this does
strike that balance it doesn't say that
you know for most of the people that
representative Smith talked about um who
are who making requests that U they're
going to be they're going to be charged
and they're going to be you know
discouraged from uh from uh making
requests but it does it does it seems to
me say that um when that if you really
are making a request that's going to
have uh a significant impact on the on
the time and commitments of public
employees and a significant cost to the
taxpayers uh then you you have to have
some skin in the game um and and it
seems to me that the that what is
requested here is not at all
unreasonable and I would note and I I
very much thank uh uh attorney biset
from the ACLU for providing information
information to us it should be noted
that many many other states we if we
adopt this requirement we're not in any
way out of the mainstream many many
other states have requirements that uh
that there of some it's it's in a
variety of different forms but
many other states have have uh
Provisions uh calling for payment um in
some circumstances and I I think this is
a very uh reasonable request um so with
that um uh it sounds like I I guess from
what I've heard from all the comments it
sounds like those who are opposed to
this um are not nobody has suggested
well if we if we um if we just amended
it in this way or that way it might be
so I take it that those who are opposed
are just opposed and uh and so with that
I guess what I'd like to ask is um a
straw vote first um who would support
this if you support this bill with
representative Cab's amendment can I
please so 12 those opposed raise your
hand
what's that oh that's that's the other
that's the other this is enabling
legislation doesn't it's not a
requirement uh no Town had would be
required to do this all right so it
looks like then the uh the ought to pass
as amended is in the majority and so for
that reason um I'm going to uh rep uh
motion I move you have to go on the
amendment first
right uh otpa on Amendment 2024 d01
97h right uh represent I recognize
representative Stapleton for a second
right all right it's been moved and
seconded U representative katab is there
anything you want
to talk if you want to speak to this
motion beyond what we've already said
please do
so um so this amendment um does add in
that if a party feels that the estimated
number of hours or costs to make the
record available is unreasonable that
they may go to the on budsman for
determination rather it's reasonable and
it does correct to say that it would
only be charged in hours of excess of 10
hours so that's that's all all right any
anyone else wish to speak on this uh
Amendment not seeing no one I uh Mr oh
yes I'm sorry okay one of the things
about um people going to the Ombudsman
there's a charge for that that's
service okay all right any other other
comments all right then I guess we're
ready for a vote on the uh this will be
a vote on the amendment ask uh just to
show hands on that can we do can we do
it with that all right so all right so
then uh all those in favor of uh of
Representative kav's Amendment please
14 I count
hand
six right all right so the amendment
passes we're now on to uh the main Bill
uh as amended anyone want anyone want to
make any further comments on the bill as
amended all right then i' ask the clerk
please Vice chairman Wallace yes rep
Alexander no rep Andrews
no rep Stapleton yes rep trip yes rep
gon
no clerk have votes yes rep Ankerberg
yes rep Smith no rep Howard yes rep De
Lorenzo no rep Kenny no rep Paige yes
rep
Divine rep lonza yes rep Lloyd yes repur
yes rep Ming yes chairman Lynn
to8 um representative kutab could I ask
you to write the majority report and um
will there be a uh Minority Report yes
they will and I'll write it all right
and Andress for the minority all right
this
all right all right so then let me uh
turn to
um uh House Bill
um there is uh again I I I want to have
at least a brief discussion about this
because based on my uh my discussion
with uh the r ranking member um it
appears that my understanding is that
that some people may may feel that
there's a little confusion and maybe
that's true and that and that perhaps
more
time uh to consider this would be in
order and let me let me sort of say what
what um what I tried to do I have an
amendment um that was based upon uh my
discussion based upon what I heard at
the hearing and my discussions uh with
representative Bickford who was a
co-sponsor um and what I what I tried to
1069 the all the the the matters that
were raised that I that I thought were
valid
points and cover both cover in 1069
9 all of the issues that were addressed
in both uh H HB 1069 and 1696 to put
them all in one bill so that if we were
to pass 1069 with the amendment we could
then itl 69 1696 because it wouldn't do
anything um and so that's what I tried
to do um but if so I guess my first
question would be
uh do people think that they need more
time to consider this and if that's the
case you know I we I'm happy to say
let's let's defer this and we'll we'll
uh we'll deal with it we'll deal with it
in the next executive session so if
somebody feels that way I'm certainly
happy to let's let's talk about
it representative Alexander thank you Mr
chair um representative Kenny and I have
an amendment to 1696 that just
incorporates the concerns from the ACLU
so we can move forward with that one if
you'd prefer and then deal with the
other one when it's up to you but I just
wanted to give you that option as well
on the table okay um all right well so
but but I mean you would be prepared to
move forward with that then today is
that is that
correct um 1696 yes okay
unless
there as long as we're holding on to one
of them I think that's fine we're
prepared to move forward with right
right right that would be the issue so
so I guess again I if if there's anybody
that thinks that we should not exec this
today and give it more you know either
either of these two bills today and give
it more time uh I'm certainly open to
doing that um but but you know if but if
not if there really isn't any any
concern and we can we could just move
forward um you know the speaker the
speaker would like to have as many uh as
many bills to to be voted on on the
floor as quickly as possible and I think
that is a valid point so
um I'm not seeing anybody saying we need
more time representative tur yeah I I
don't know what um representative
Alexander's Amendment would or wouldn't
do um I guess my problem was the idea of
pushing both of these together into the
same bill um because personally I feel
differently on 1069 and
1696 um and the changes that came in
your Amendment um didn't just bring in
the language from the other bill they
also brought in a lot of other content
and so I wasn't sure where that would
leave this bill if uh we didn't spend
more time because it feels like there
isn't a version of it that at least from
my perspective I'm comfortable with
because it it sort of is bringing two
very different issues together under one
One
Umbrella okay um yes representative
Kenny thank you Mr chair uh so like
representative Alexander said uh we do
have an amendment PR prepared for 1696
um and I do agree with that Amendment
but like representative tur just said um
some people may feel one way about um
one of these bills and not the other and
although I understand what the amendment
is trying to do to merge them I think if
we wait on one we should wait on both um
just so people can have enough time um
to consider and um think about these
separately and together thank you no
that's all right so so let me ask you
let me put it let me put it this way uh
we've had at least two people have
spoken in uh have suggested that it
would that there would be some benefit
to waiting um does anybody have an OP is
anybody opposed to us deferring action
on these two bills until you know until
another another executive session
representative
Stapleton I like the way the two came
together and uh I would support moving
it
Forward right um let me ask okay let
well in the in the interest of trying to
come to an bipartisan uh result here can
I just ask how many if if you if you
favor moving forward now without delay
without putting it off to another time
can I ask you to raise your hand please
can I ask a clarifying question if we're
moving forward with 1069 does that mean
that we could still hold 1696 if
if they wanted to sure so we other words
I I suppose we what what I had thought
was if we did 1069 with the Amendments I
had proposed there would be no need for
1696 because we would have addressed
that issue and so my thought was we
would we if we passed 1069 with with the
amendment otpa then the logical thing to
do would be to itl 1696 but we don't
have to do that we could otpa
1069 and leave and and uh just not take
any action on
1696 leave that so that it would be open
for you know for another amendment or do
so later I I don't have any problem with
that um but it sounds like
representative tur and representative
Kenny are saying that it it might make
more sense to just not do it today so
that everybody has a better has more
time to think about it and I'm not I'm
not opposed to that either but uh and it
sounded like from when I when I asked
people to raise their hands that there
was only a few people who thought we
should move forward today but let me ask
again if you fa if you think we should
move forward today on these two bills
hand all right so I
only
well I so all right so I guess what I'm
going to do then is say let's not move
forward on either 1069 or
1696 and we'll take that up at the the
um at uh at our next executive session
which I want to talk about before we
leave today um then let me next turn to
uh
103 uh that's the uh Bill uh regarding
name changes uh for uh prisoners and I
understand there's an amendment um by
representative kutab so I'm going to
recognize representative
d205 is there a second yeah me Mr chair
all right moved in seconded uh
representative katab we wish to speak to
uh representative
Alexander representative katab you wish
Amendment so the amendment simply added
a few of the
uh convictions that were missing that
were pointed out by the Coalition of
domestic violence um and it also adds in
that before the Probate Court May Grant
a name
change that a reasonable effort should
be made by the initial Prosecuting
District to notify the victim and that
it all right anyone else wish to be
all right seeing no one um so I guess
we're ready then for a vote on the
amendment and it's amendment
0205 is that correct yeah do we want do
that sure I can do I think we can do
that by hand um so uh all those in favor
hand it seems appears to be uh we have
one missing I guess so
uh 19 19
20 right right we have representative
gon missing so I think it's 190 so it's
19 z um all right so that passes and
we're on to uh the the bill uh as
amended otpa uh anyone wish to speak uh
on the bill as amended seeing none I'd
ask the clerk to call the role
please
Vice chairman Wallace yes rep Alexander
yes rep Andrews yes rep testerman yes re
Stapleton yes re trip
yes clerk kab votes yes re
inberg yes rep
Smith re Howard yes re dorenzo yes rep
Kenny
yes rep
pagee rep Divine yes rep lonza yes rep
Lloyd yes RIP
turer yes rep Ming yes chairman Lynn yes
motion passes 19
to um can that go on consent anybody
yeah no anybody have any problem consent
all right consent um and um
representative kab you um if you get all
right if you get loaded down with
reports don't hesitate to let me know
and I'll I'll be happy to write one for
you all right
um all right the next one
um on our agenda is uh
2004 which is to uh repeal the judicial
conduct commission uh
um again I'm going to recognize
representative katab uh or uh that bill
I move
OTP is there a second I will
second um representative kab do you wish
motion so this is just simply seeking to
clean up the books on something that
cannot be used it was deemed
unconstitutional I understand why many
parties want to be able to use it but I
I do think it's a you know a 73a issue
where if something like this were to be
used then the proper way to do this
would we we would need a constitutional
amendment and so right now there is a
Judicial conduct committee that's part
of the court and this is repealing the
statutory commission they both have very
similar names abbreviated JCC I think
it's really confusing especially to
prosay parties that perhaps want to make
a complaint about a judge they go to
look up the process they find this on
the books they don't realize that it's
not used I think that's incredibly
confusing and so I think it makes sense
to clean up the books again it was it
was deemed unconstitutional 20 years ago
so I think it's it's been sitting on
there long enough not used that we
should go ahead and take care of it
anyone else wish to be heard on uh on
this
bill all right then I guess we're ready
uh for um a roll call on it uh the
motion is ought to pass on uh repealing
the statute so i' ask the cour to call r
v chairman Wallace yes rep Alexander yes
rep Andrews yes rep testerman yes rep
Stapleton yes rep trip yes rep
GRE clerk could have votes yes rep
inberg
yes rep Smith yes rep
Howard oh uh rep De Lorenzo
yes re Kenny yes rep
Paige rep Divine yes rep lonza
yes rep Lloyd yes repur yes rep Ming yes
chairman
yes motion passes 18
to0 uh again can that go on consent
don't see any reason why it could
not
uh I'll I'll write the I I'll write the
one um all right uh next we're on to
um House Bill a th000 5
um relating to uh judicial
training
um and I will uh recognize
representative there's an amendment I
will rep recognize representative uh
trip uh on the amendment um I'll make a
motion to uh uh otpa on House Bill 1
Z5 right and what and the amendment
what's the amendment
number
93h that's Amendment 0193
and um am I correct the only
thing uh that does um and I guess I'll
direct my question to representative
kabi the only thing that does is change
May to Shell is that correct that's
correct and I think that was suggested
by both you representative katab and by
representative Smith um I think it makes
sense for the reasons we that was were
stated
we stated at the at the hearing so
anyone want does anyone yes repres I'm
sorry and I apologize the committee I
was introducing a bill in the other
committee when this was brought up okay
um was there any like problem with the
now
representative
so right now there
is uh
I sure represent recognize
representative
Smith hello
everybody
um as you know for a number of reasons a
special committee on the Family Court um
was formed with five members of the
judici Judiciary Committee and five
members of um children and family law we
were focusing only on the Family Court a
part of the Circuit Court we weren't
focusing on um the Superior or the
Supreme Court but we will move to form a
special committee looking at education
training and
accountability and um we came to realize
that for many many reasons and I can
discuss a few of the most significant um
it was very hard for members of the
judicial AR to get access to the
training that they that everyone
understood they needed one of the
reasons is um they didn't have enough uh
time because the judges um are in the
court all the time in the Family Court
they have no no attorneys they have no
staff assistance so they're doing both
judicial work and what I would call
judicial administrative work um there is
no uh there's very very limited money um
available for any training there is no
possibility of having uh scheduling
controlled in such a way to provide
reasonable access to time time is always
the most difficult of all to control and
um the result is that that
subcommittee um came to realize that the
that the legislature has an
obligation to make it possible for the
courts to do what they would like to do
what they know is necessary but they
need some support from the the
legislative branch and
um therefore the answer is
yes there is a a problem in ter not
necessarily because of lack of will but
lack of time and resources on the part
of the judicial branch and we can help
make it possible without violating 73a
without the legislature taking over um
the responsibilities that belong in the
courts to nonetheless make it possible
for the judges to do a better job
meeting the needs to decisions of the
state and that is why um uh I and and
others support this legislation with the
amendment to um emphasize its
importance so does that does that it it
does answer my question I
guess when you mentioned the 73a we just
passed a bill that repealed legislator
accountability and now we're passing a
bill that adds more legislature
accountability I guess I'm like I'm
going to vote for the bill it answers
the question but I guess I'm I'm
confused why we're we shouldn't have a
position then we should have a position
representative Alexander to help me
understand why this bill is increasing
legislative
accountability um uh I the court has no
Authority on its own to uh uh
to ra to to
fund the branch the legislature is
responsible for that um it is one
example of how the branches work
together this is setting a
policy
um that falls within our Province uh to
um in in terms of of Staffing and
funding and that's what that is what
this what the uh chief justice does um
you know is up to him and um we're not
stepping on his toes I did have a long
conversation with uh the chief uh last
either Thursday afternoon or Friday
morning um uh to clarify some
misunderstandings that he had about what
we would doing and I believe that he was
quite
comfortable um at the end of that
conversation as was I with the out come
of that
conversation thank you
I I'm not trying to belabor this but
we're saying they shall complete
training we're not just giving them
$156,000 to hire a coordinator than they
they determine the training we're
telling them how much training to have
so in one lock in one one bill we're
repealing something so that they have
more control
over that conduct commission and then in
another breath we're creating a position
so that we can then tell them how much
training they must have that is that is
my issue I'm going to vote for the bill
and support the bill I guess I'm just
trying to bring that point up I I hear
what you're saying and I think it's it's
quite it's quite a valuable Point very
clearly we are not saying anyway what
that training will be who is to perform
the training what the substance of the
training is we leave it to the court to
saying it's okay for you to take those
the
judges from the
bench for a limit and others it's not
just the judges it's other staff um in
order to do what you the court want to
do and we will fulfill Our obligation
although it's not in this bill um but
it's something of a moral obligation to
make sure that when the finance
committee gets the budget that we
support the efforts of the Supreme Court
position all right any other any other
uh comment yes representative staple
I don't see anywhere in the bill that it
prescribes U methods
or curriculum of instruction and that's
what's up to the
coordinator who will be
familiar with the craft and um I can
only relate similarly to the insurance
business where we had to do 24 hours of
continuing
education three four or five credit
credits of which had to be ethics and
but it was specialized um and in
commercial um liability and property um
the the the online courses were
specially tailored to the the licensed
requirements of the State of New
Hampshire and um I believe that that
possibility is open here the coordinator
may have a number of resources to
utilize and Marshall the best uh
curricular
to fit the need here I'm entirely
comfortable with the way the bill is
written yes representative Alexander
thank you Mr chair the way I'm reading
this amendment and maybe it's a drafting
error at ol I don't know but I'm reading
it
as line seven the minimum initial
training for judges shall be as follows
and then it tells them orientation for
new judges on procedures and function of
the Court education for new judges on
legal subjects practical skills needed
at least one hour of training devoted to
topics of legal judicial ethics
professionalism preventing implicit bias
mental health domestic violence are we
telling them what they should learn or
not because I was just told we're not
but then the way the Amendments drafted
we're telling them what they need to be
trained on I think I think the the what
we're telling them is sort of the
general areas in other words the the
um this you know I'm always I'm always
sort of uh to some extent um uh Curious
when this the the because the issue is
raised
uh sometimes I think really
inappropriately by by uh uh the judicial
branch or its spokesman not I'm not
suggesting that this has happened
recently at all I don't mean to suggest
that but in the past there was a view I
think on uh some people that uh the
court had
some uh special uh separation of powers
responsibility so the legislature really
couldn't do anything uh or almost
anything uh relating to uh the details
of Court operations uh because it was a
somehow could be a violation of
separation of powers because it was one
branch telling the other and usually
completely absent from any of those
discussions was the fact that the
legislature has done exactly that with
the executive branch um I uh uh in in
whatever areas it came up and so uh
finally there this uh there was a um a
decision I'm happy to say that I wrote
it I when I just coincidentally that
attempted to uh and it was a unanimous
decision that attempted to sort of make
it clear that the the legislature would
cross the line only if it interfered
with the uh the the essential judicial
function
uh essential judicial functions of
adjudicating cases and so this um you
know I I guess I would
agree that if that there would be some
point at which the leg the legislature
would go too far not only with the
judicial branch but with the Executive
Branch if it really tried to micromanage
training but simply saying what the
level of training must be that there
must be 12 hours or or 24 hours whatever
uh the general topics that need to be
covered um I don't that that is
something that the legislature has done
for the executive branch in many in many
with many agencies um and so I don't see
that at at any as any problem at all um
it doesn't in any way interfere with how
courts decide individual cases or what
uh what law they must apply in
individual cases so I don't see any any
uh separation of powers violation here
at all and I agree with representative
Smith and I and uh and representative
Cab's uh point that it's it certainly
was
true during the time that I was in the
judicial branch and I think given the
what's what happened with covid and
those kind of things I'm sure it's even
more true today that
um
training um was always something
something that there was because there
was not a particular person assigned
with that
responsibility it was always something
that the court tried I think the courts
very at the various levels tried to do
their best to provide training but it
was always something that um you know
was not there was nobody specifically
designed to to do that and so it
it when it when it was my responsibility
to do that it was something that you
know we but we got to do this training
let's let's let's get somebody to do it
and and uh you know and it was sort of
an ad hoc kind of thing which is really
not the best way for that to happen I
think the having a training coordinator
will be a very positive uh positive
thing representative trip
uh I believe I have to agree with rep
Alexander that there's a there's a
wording problem on uh line seven and
eight uh the first section talks about
initial training for uh uh for new hires
where the uh the line eight talks about
minimum initial training for the judges
I I believe what it should be saying is
judges
yes oh so it it actually is right
because it then says that like it's
because this amendment is only changing
the shell pieces and so the paragraphs
that didn't say shell aren't in here but
if you compare the two together it does
underneath of the initial training it
then says orientation for new judges on
procedures and functions of the
applicable court and relevant procedural
and subst of law um so it it lists
several things and then the next
paragraph um is any person who holds a
position of Judge Court Administrator so
it it does make sense actually it's just
it some of the paragraphs were changed
and some weren't so when they are merged
back together the language would make
sense other other
comments All right so um seeing none I
guess we're ready uh first for a vote on
uh the amendment and I can do that by
show of hands I ask all those in favor
of uh Amendment 0
20241 93h please raise your
hand
uh appears to be 19 to0 all
right um then any further discussion on
the bill as
amended seeing none I'd ask the clerk to
call the role please Vice chairman
Wallace yes rep Alexander
no rep Andrews yes rep testerman yes rep
Stapleton yes rep trip
yes
clerk have votes yes rep Ankerberg yes
rep Smith yes rep Howard yes rep D
Lorenzo yes rep Kenny yes rep Paige yes
rep Divine yes rep lonza yes rep Lloyd
yes re tur yes rep Ming
yes chairman Lynn
yes motion passes 18
to1 go on
consent all right consent uh oh wait a
minute no no this is this I think I
think it has to go this is a this is
going to go to a second committee
there's a fiscal note so it probably
can't go going to a second it yeah it is
your saying that there's AIS doesn't
necessarily right no I'm let me see yeah
it's on it's an early Bill unfortunately
okay um so it can't go on consent yes it
can oh because because fiscal I think it
that's yeah I can't go on consent okay
so
um
0193 um and um representative trip could
I ask you to write the
report all right um all right
um okay think that represent Alexander
will there be any Minority Report okay
um all
right all right then next I'd like to
turn to
um what I hb1 1274 which what I have
referred to as the judicial cleanup bill
um uh
and
um
second so
um representative uh I have an amendment
um
0180 which
adds um the
uh move moves uh from 75,000 to 100,000
the um the the uh ability of the
judicial branch to make Interline
transfers doesn't change the budget at
all but it make it increases that amount
from 75,000 to 100,000 I
as as I
recall uh from the hearing U the this
this change to 100,000 was made on a for
a number of other you know in another
number of other parts of the budget and
for some reason it didn't get I think
just an oversight it didn't get put in
the judicial branch one and so that's
what this change is for um but um before
we get to V votes um representative
turer I understand you have another
amendment which would have if I
understand correctly
eliminated um the witness fees and
mileage section is that is that correct
and can I ask you to speak to that just
for a minute sure I I passed it around
it's uh 0189 H um and yeah from from the
discussion in the
testimony uh the question was in that
section it
specifies um mileage amounts and and
other dollar amounts um that seemed out
of step with the sort of current um
reimbursement levels for those things
and and in the discussion um the council
basically said they're already paying
these rates they basically are are
authorized through another um section of
law to make the payments they just don't
have guidance on what the payments
should be but they also seem to suggest
that this is just the old language that
that was in place when this it seems
like potentially accidentally fell out
of an amendment to an to the RSA so it
felt as though there was no real reason
to put the wrong numbers back in statute
now if it's not
preventing the council from making the
payments the way they are anyway and
that would provide the time to figure
out what the right um amounts are and
and whether that actually is properly in
statute or or or dealt with through some
other mechanism Like rules so that was
my reason for for taking that out so so
you know what I I guess um uh
my I don't really have any problem with
what you what you suggest and and I
think you're my my understanding of of
you know the situation I think is the
same as yours the only question I have
and I see a representative of the
judicial branch the back of the room is
um is if and I wonder if I just could
ask you to come up for a minute so I can
we can just ask you a question if we
do what representative tur suggests that
is we simply remove the section of this
bill that
reinstated the Mage rate and witness fee
rates um as I understand it from the
testimony we heard even without this
language um in the in current law the
judicial branch is paying people at the
at this rate um under sort of General
Authority from another statute is is
that
correct good morning Mr chairman uh eron
K and general counsel for the judicial
branch um I believe that the judicial
councel um or judicial Council I'm sorry
yes does pay because they are obligated
to under another statute and so even
though the specific guidance of this
statute was repealed they are following
it in the absence of more clear guidance
in order to comply with the Mandate of
another statute okay so if we if we do
what representative tur suggests that is
we just remove that language from Bill
that's not gonna there's not going to be
any problem as far as you're aware with
the with the judicial Council just
continuing to do what they've been doing
not that I'm aware of right and then if
there's some need and then presumably
next year in the budget or whatever if
we if if it's thought that we should up
the witness fees and the mileage
allowance whatever we can do that next
year that is my understanding as well
sir okay all right so in with that um my
inclination is that representative tur's
amendment is a good one and we ought to
adopt that um does any but does anyone
else anyone have any other thoughts on
witness all right oh representative St
pleas I'm good with uh moving it forward
with that Amendment great thank you very
much appreciate that we have two we
amendments first I guess I'll move um my
um Amendment first which is where where
is it um my amendment is the one that
that changes the uh 75,000 to 100,00 and
that is
20248 um so um can I ask for a show of
hands of those in favor of uh adopting
Amendment
0180 please raise your hand if you're in
that looks like it's unanimous 19
to0
um oh I'm sorry I need yes can I have a
second first on the
motion all right so I have
representative uh Wallace second
um
yes no it's it's I'm I'm sorry you know
what it no it's there was an
81h that was first sent around but that
was uh OS corrected that because they
hadn't um you'll see that
0180 H is a just a bit different in in
that it um the effective date of another
section was not included in the first
version so they corrected that so it's
actually the right amendment is
0180 which I think is what we voted on
um and that so the motion was uh made
Amendment all
right
then
right1 uh that's 018 right1 0180 it was
the one we just passed all right and now
I'm going to
uh I'm going to uh
turn to um representative
tur's uh Amendment which is
0189 H um and ask for a show of hands on
that all if you're in favor of adopting
also all right now we're on to uh the
main
Bill oh um it's a good question yeah I'm
so representative I assume that you
moved to adopt your
Amendment yes thank you Mr and I will
second
it um just so we make sure we doubt all
the eyes and cross all the te um all
right and so now we're on to uh the bill
as amended by the two
amendments um anyone wish to speak
further on uh on this bill all right
then I ask the clerk to please call the
role of otpa on um hb1
1274 Vice chairman Wallace yes rep
Alexander yes rep Andrews yes rep
testerman yes rep Steepleton yes rep
trip yes rep GRE oh clerk could have
votes yes rep Ankerberg yes rep Smith
yes rep Howard yes rep deal Renzo yes
rep Kenny
yes rep
Paige
rep Divine yes rep lonza yes rep wood
yes repur yes rep Ming yes chairman Lynn
yes motion passes 19 to0 any reason oh
well um is this one is this a consent go
no I
don't yeah let me just see if that's if
that was one of the
1274 hang on um 1274 is not an early
bill so that can go on consent anybody
object to it being on
consent all right
consent um all right and then lastly our
last uh item of business is
um House Bill
1489 uh this is the bill that would deal
with uh town and School District ballot
recount
appeals
um and um at least in our caucus there
was uh some discussion of of this uh
this being an appropriate bill for
interim study uh and I'd like to rec uh
I was going to recognize representative
gson uh but representative
Stapleton did we miss something or I
missed something uh we voted
on 0180 H and 0189 H but did we not have
a vote on the
otpa no we did we did have was that okay
we did vote on that y we did on I'll
catch up no no problem no problem so um
in the absence of Representative gon um
I will move uh for interim
study on uh on uh House Bill
1489 uh and is there a second
representative
Stapleton all right um so um if I may
speak to the motion um at least an hour
caucus and I'd be interested in knowing
what you know what the what the other
caucus felt about this our discussion
was a couple of things first that it
appeared that um This was
um this bill was was designed uh in
response to a particular situation and
we I think many of us had concerns about
whether it's a a good thing to adopt
legislation in response to just sort of
one incident particularly where we
haven't seen a lot of
uh you know haven't we haven't gotten a
lot of input that there's been uh there
that this has been a continuing problem
I think we only had one witness who
testified at the hearing um and the
second thought was that maybe this is
just
something um that requires uh further
study if there were going to be um if we
were if we
were what this bill would do is change
what's known in the legal world as the
American Rule and the American rule
basically is that in
in in most areas of the
law um if you want an attorney uh you
pay your own attorney whether you win or
lose you pay your own attorney um we
have
some that's that law that American rule
has been changed and there are a number
of instances in which it is allowed
under statute to shift the the attorney
um fee uh to the other side usually in
in favor of the the usually providing
that the prevailing party is entitled to
recover their attorney's fees in civil
rights cases for example some consumer
protection cases there are other areas
but still the rule the general rule
remains that um if you hire an attorney
you pay for the attorney whether you win
or lose that's the American rule this
would propose to change that for these
particular types of appeals of recount
decisions only at the local level um and
so one of the thoughts that uh that
people had and I think it's a legitimate
one
is if there was
enough trouble in this area that we
thought we ought to make such a
change um first we would we ought to
have more evidence that it really is a
problem which we don't have and secondly
that um maybe it would require maybe if
we were going to make a change it
shouldn't just be limited to the local
level but it should be you know for
recounts at the state level too you
would you would make that change I don't
know whether that's a good idea or not
but maybe that's something that deserves
further study so that's why um our
caucus at least thought that interim
study made sense and I'd be interested
in hearing from the ranking
member you're not bored yet from hearing
from me not at all okay
um my personal view is that this should
be
itl it is not a question of recount it's
a question of not accepting the findings
of the recount um and it's then
challenging the recount which is yet
another step um and I think this does
Fall Again into the category of using
one particular
circumstance to make law that affects
everyone um so I I
would support itl and my sense is that
if not all almost all of my colleagues
agreed with that on the Democratic side
but I will if for any reason you think
it's more appropriate to do interim
study I wouldn't object to that I would
just point out to everybody that we're
early in our uh in the Committee hearing
process this um session and I remind you
that um if you vote interim study that
means you're going to have to do
something with the bill over the summer
or in the early fall at about the same
time that we have um primaries and
general elections so I would take
seriously um your commitment to put
invest time in this particular Bill
understanding there might be other bills
that have a
broader impact um that will come before
us but if you're willing to commit to
the time I'm certainly not going to
object to
that wisdom of experience wisdom of
experience um so let me ask uh just uh
for a show of hands May mainly from my
caucus I guess uh does uh what
representative Smith uh says has said uh
change your mind if it does you may
raise your hand and I will be the first
to do that her message
carries so I'm going to withdraw my
motion and recognize representative
so I drew the Short Straw
again um uh Mr chair with respect to the
genuine concern of the Prime sponsor of
this bill nonetheless I would um move um
itl second by representative Wallace um
there any further
discussion on this bill all right uh
seeing none I would ask the clerk to
call the role
please Vice chairman Wallace yes ref
Alexander yes rep Andrews yes re
testerman yes rep Stapleton yes rep trip
yes CL could have votes yes rep
Ankerberg yes rep Smith yes rep Howard
yes rep D Lorenzo yes rep Kenny yes rep
p
yes rep Divine yes rep lonza yes rep
Lloyd yes repur yes rep Ming yes
chairman Lynn yes motion passes 19
to0 all right uh and this can go uh
consent any reason it can't go on
consent nope all right consent
um and I will write the report
thank
um all right um so
um that's that kind of concludes our
business except for one thing I I would
like to um I'd like to talk just for a
moment about um schedu I I've now
scheduled out all of the hearings that
are of the bills that are before our
committee and I think it takes us up to
February 21st first
um and I had some discussion with a
ranking member about um scheduling
executive sessions I know that there was
some sentiment and you may be right that
um I scheduled this one a little too
early so I um I going forward I think it
probably makes sense to have at least a
full week uh between the time we hear
Bill actually more more maybe would end
up being a week and a half if we have
our our our hearings on Wednesdays uh
before we have executive sessions um but
um representative uh Smith has suggested
that perhaps the way to proceed is not
to schedule any executive sessions until
after February
21st or maybe make the first one as you
know the February 21st we don't have a
full day that's the last day of our
hearings we don't have a full day um so
we could schedule some executive
sessions then um I'm
just I'm a little bit worried about
doing that just because I'm uh I as I
said the speaker is really on a rooll to
get to have us get bills to him as
quickly as possible I don't I don't
think I think we've done a pretty good
job on in that regard but um what I
might do I guess I would say is this I
might schedule one executive session
between now and February 21st um and
then
schedule another executive session for
that day and and maybe and and perhaps
later um so that every everyone will
have enough time um there'll be no sort
of time pressure uh on on uh bills um
and what I would say is in terms of
dates in terms of days it probably will
end up having to be on a Monday with the
because we're going to be having
sessions every Thursday and that's the
only um other day right now that the
room that this room is available so
would probably end up having to be on
Monday on a Monday um with the one
caveat that state and federal has the
has this room on Fridays and they as I
understand it have a relatively uh small
number of bills before them so if they
finish up their hearings pretty quickly
and and a Friday is available I might
schedule the uh the hearing the
executive session on Friday
representative Alexander thank you Mr
chair um this is something where I have
a lot of pride in the Judiciary
Committee because typically the
Judiciary Committee agrees more often
than it disagrees so my only suggestion
is that whenever possible and we have a
full committee maybe we hear a bill one
week and the next week after public
hearings if we have a consensus or what
appears to be a consensus we exec right
after a public hearing just to take care
of some of the ones where we have have
consensus on sure no I'm I I think that
makes sense and I'm obviously under the
rule it would require my agreement and
the with the ranking member but if we
have that I fine on that representative
um Mr chair in order to exec a
bill um after a public hearing it has to
be with our agreement that day it can't
be another day the rule says it has to
be that day so while I appreciate
representative Alexander's suggestion I
don't think we could do it the next day
unless we had in fact put it on the
calendar that's number one number two I
I greatly admire your commitment to the
speaker
um uh
recommendation I too share his belief
that we don't want to pile all the bills
so that we're here at the end but we are
way ahead of what other committees have
done we have the bills we worked on last
week uh with such pleasure um and we
have the bills that we worked on
today um those are all now going to be
out there other committees are also
beginning to do what they should
do I would suggest that the in
convenience we cause at least some of
our
members who are juggling a lot of other
responsibilities by meeting on a day
other than Wednesday except in an
emergency really isn't
Justified we have a relatively short
calendar if I remember correctly on the
21st which means that we can add to that
day in the afternoon exing on certain
bills that we will have heard a few
weeks earlier so that gets a few more
out there and then when we come back
after the break all relaxed and happy we
can immediately begin um the first week
in March to um exec and we can get
through spent a whole day exing and we
can do that
without forcing people who are otherwise
working or or meeting um family
obligations uh
to upset their schedule so I would
really hope that except in an emergency
you would let us stick to Wednesdays
unless there's just no
alternative yes representative K would
it be possible say were hearing bills on
on Wednesday of one week the following
Wednesday to
notice some of the bills to put at the
end of the hearings that way we could
have a week to think about them but then
they'd still be on a Wednesday because
my only thought is that when we pile all
of them at the end it can get hard to
remember all of the testimony from all I
think we have
30 two more bills left or something yeah
it's quite it is quite
um yes of course I just the days that I
I don't have it in front of me but the
what I have seen of what the chair has
done is except for the
21st he has filled the days with
hearings and um with the last one
frequently being something like at 3:30
um we'd have to then move some some of
those and I think all of us would prefer
to have well I don't know but I mean I
think it makes more sense to uh to make
sure we go through the bill so that we
have enough time if we need work
sessions or subcommittees to do it but
we have um we have a lot of time and we
are we I think we' more than fulfilled
Our obligation I'd also like to point
out something that representative
Alexander said that
relevant uh particularly relevant as all
of his comments are and that is that
because we are so frequently in
agreement we have so many bills that
we're putting on
consent that means that the speaker does
not have to be concerned about the
amount of
time that is going to be added to the
calendars by bills coming from the
Judiciary Committee so I I really I mean
obviously I'm I'm going to agree with
whatever you do Mr chairman but um I I
know that um a number of
my of of the Democrats and it's probably
so for the Republicans to actually work
for a living and um I know that's an
oldfashioned concept but it's one that I
respect I mean i' want if somebody would
hire me I'd be glad to work for a living
but nobody seems to want to hire me and
so it's just it's a hard it's hard for
people to add another day and and I
guess my point is we don't have to and
can still fulfill our obligations I
don't know perhaps representative
Wallace has a different take on that
thank you for the leading um I'm just
sure we did uh historically in the
criminal justice committee a our say a
little bit busier committee we would
notice that we would have public
hearings when time permit so if we do
have you mean session 15 minutes we
finish up a bill we could take a
an uncon an uncontested Bill take that
up exec and we could do that throughout
the day as well right that's that's we
get some options I think we'll probably
work it out so you know as I look at
this I I see let me suggest this um as I
looked at the schedule on the uh it's
not on the
14th we have our last hearing schedule
for 1145 as opposed to uh there's none
at 2:30 or 3:15 so we would have some
time that afternoon noon and then as the
as representative Smith pointed out on
the 21st which is our last day of
hearings we we only have hearings
scheduled for the morning so maybe
between that's good between doing an
executive session on some bills on the
14th more on the
21st and then also
um representative Smith and I can be can
be sort of mindful of when we have bills
coming up including even this Wednesday
if we have bills coming up that it looks
like you know we've we it appears from
the hearing that we are all kind of in
agreement uh we may be able to EXA those
right away at the end of the day so
maybe by doing all of those things um we
can stick to Wednesdays and I will uh
that sounds like a reasonable way to go
and I'll try to do that
yes thank you for just like make let me
take um have a comment I want to just
thank um was say I say Mar
uh um representative Smith for making
the comment yes um we do some of us do
work a lot of um hours and stuff and
still um come here to try to make a
difference and so I just want to say it
would be very appreciative if we could
stay on Wednesdays that would be great
and um I agree too if whatever is going
to be the easiest for us to go for is uh
the best thing so thank you
great all right um so uh that's at least
you know tentatively that's that will be
my plan to have an exec session on the
in the afternoon on the 14th another one
on the 21st and then uh and hopefully
try to get to exec some of the bills
we're going to be hearing over between
now and then at the end of the day if if
uh representative Smith and I are in
agreement and it appears that we have uh
consensus um the only thing left I have
to I have to ask is with regard to
people that are writing reports on
today's executive session could I
request that you have them to me uh see
are we gonna make the yeah can I ask
request that you have them to me by the
end of the day
tomorrow um so that I can get those and
I will get them in right away um all
right great any anything else that we
need to
discuss great I guess we're adjourned
then thank you very much thank you you
right trying to make it easier for you
you
didn't sure yeah yeah now I will do
that that's how we have that bill we
the
that